yes the mother the white I'm welcome
everyone to Hawaii
roll the intro leave your entries and
leave your entry close oh boy we have
one of the most top voted of all time
this week is that right 126,000 mr. B's
hitting twenty million trees and it
rhymes
it rhymes omedetou bestest i cameto
gozaimasu yes well done everyone what a
massive effort so many people came
together to make this possible I think
it's it's a testimony of what the
Internet can do and I'm really really
proud of everyone involved I think
that's super cool this sort of stuff
does not get enough attention but I hope
it will I'm looking at you news media
through something poke him with the
stick hate prove you're not just a bunch
of Bing bongs alright getting a lot of
uploads realizing people are only up
voting because they want free coins wait
what is that how wait what
how does ready work I still don't know
mr. beefs got robbed ten mo go ten mo go
10 Emma I'd never want to hear her
stinky name again
she's just like Trisha Paytas level of I
don't care she's like to flight earth in
there as a concept I don't care just
shut up
team trees nearly got 20 mil we need to
do an effect account you need top but
it's free so confused is that why is
that why it's gotten so many uploads
this week Jesus Christ what did they
change on reddit stop reporting stuff
you [ __ ] crybabies God I'm gonna do
it
68 traffic deaths this year I'm gonna do
what's called a pro game that's a good
meme nice how mom peels potato how I
peel potato it's funny because it's true
not gonna lie though this version of
Tesla truck looks skin dope right that
looks cool I don't know how I feel about
the cyber truck now
damnit Tabak god save the queen' nut and
go Navy are protected yeah you should
have just had go go away how about that
nineteen million trees oh yeah it's all
coming together and it did it did that
went so fast in the end who who'd made
the final were a lot of people just
sitting on their donations so they could
be like yeah I did that you're welcome
it's whatever people who don't it in the
beginning be like oh me ignoring
everyone who got ready coins because I'm
jealous 250 reddit coins
what is this 250 right I don't
understand reddit I am such a Boomer I'm
too boomer to be on this can you imagine
in the future I'm still doing this
everything will be so confusing I'm
already confused hipster snake was born
with ironic mustache and sunglasses you
will never be this cool you will never
be as cool as hipster snake first of all
why is it a hipster snake second of it
all why is it an ironic mustache don't
you don't know the intent of snake sound
man he hurts to be this here a hungry
kid called 911 so cops brought him Pizza
Pizza time cool when I call the cop is
like yeah we'll be right there 20 hours
later sweetie pie was like father to me
is that real did he actually say that I
loved him like he was my son
it's amazing how I don't miss where at
all a man named Walter Summerford was
struck by lightning three times in his
life after his death his gravestone was
also struck I'm still worthy lightning
never society lights society lies Frick
Twitter nice very nice
I was so worried that video would come
across as preachy I was trying I think
it already kind of is but yeah freak
Twitter pewds us fanbase Pierce European
fanbase me in South Africa OS is a merge
reference though it is why no shipping
go manic
oh I don't know I don't know I don't
know why are you living South Africa
bruh like
you can live anywhere the pupil of your
eye can expand as much as 55% while
looking at someone you love even sadder
is that your name reminded me of an
online friend who has the same user name
on Instagram aqua sky
she has been an on for two years I miss
you babe bro that's me wait what
bro that's me no freaking way
yes it's me did I miss you so much you
really went like I am a head out depth
let's left us on the rocks how are you
hope you're doing well pretty good I
left Instagram because it's stressful so
wholesome oh my god the music fits so
well as well my god him I'm not that
rich also him I don't understand that's
not money
god I'm gay I'm gay I'm too old for this
redditors who got it already
me uploading every post I see to get 250
coin where's my daughter affected coins
what do I have 2,000 measly 2000 L Oh
God I finally met pop appearance after 8
years of loving him can't believe it
this is so nice yeah there was a bunch
of Swedish people that recognize me at
the airport I'm wearing same thing you
two have the exact same expression
it's an introvert thing you wouldn't
understand I feel like we need a secret
word if you ever see me just say okay I
got it I got it
so if you ever see me ask me if it's
math related to science that way I know
you're an epic nine year old or 19 year
old 19 role and not some cloud chaser
okay got it all right cool whoa
two chairs that's two pow he's too
powerful to keep alive kill kill kill
two chairs kids you have big peepee also
Pierce in another video you have small
peepee my peepee I will not write this
for further confusion this PP
inconclusive PP the first guy to use the
same face for a headphone l must have
been like
Oh God I've become the very thing I
swore to destroy Oh No
I can't believe I'm still doing it for
so long
murmurs it's this video game
do they really think that it's ready to
video game can i play it can i buy it
for my son for christmas me when the
internet goes down for more than three
seconds I get it it's the dinosaur game
right that's hilarious
small peepee dude says he's gonna take a
break it was not pewdiepie it was
puppies Moria puppies Moria deserves a
break big peepee energy it made me laugh
I don't deserve to be creator of the
year you can say that again pal yikes
some cringe yeah frozen but instead the
king and queen has two dogs and their
own product line is that Sookie I think
it says Sookie and Sue caveat ha ha cool
how's it goin brows my name it
you're the verge of greatness we were
this close
when reddit sees the number of posts all
voted by me in the last hour just zero
real freaking quick big peepee energy
like I saw talk money let's go
alcohol because no great story ever
started with a glass of milk
checkmate boomers check mate I'm a tiny
swedish youtuber wait how oh my God if
he's tiny can you imagine how tiny the
figurine is the figuri must be like this
tiny if he's this tiny oh my god I'm
joking and it's not even that funny man
that's so cool
actually it is that small Jesus squid my
miniatures on YouTube that's really
tough oh my god Edgar's so fat I love
the Minecraft sword as well and the fire
texture that's so do Ken this video get
same likes as dislikes some things never
end
some things never change a YouTube can
change system but some things will never
change YouTube
people getting ready coins me not even
knowing what they are that's a great
mean template it's made with me Mehta
gig scientists find Mozambique untouched
rainforest on top of an African mountain
great don't touch it don't ruin it don't
touch it don't ruin it taking a break
because of fatigue taking a break to
grow out of beard without the awkward
middle of stage I was actually thinking
about that it could be a good time to
grow out of my beard damn it oh how do I
have that power I don't understand when
you see your favorite youtuber yelling
at you confuse happiness I would I
explained in another video that I was
going to do this but Marsha has stopped
in me by rolling up the window YouTube
rewind should have parodied a vendor's
end game with all the youtubers going
back to fix rewind that is so sad and
the Internet has the best ideas that's a
great idea
what a loss of virginity that's so good
oh my god I was so funny you can see it
in front of me
you could have Elon Musk in it being our
actual Iron Man I'm sure he'd be down to
it my crippling depression from not
getting a comment Edgar the Pug but damn
is it me or is it me and the boys
appearing one more time before the
decade ends all right there it is gamers
there it is a good pirate never takes
another person's property isn't this a
paradox that means a bad pirate takes
another person's property but that makes
a bad pirate a good pirate because
that's what I mean trying to get this
last pivot do you feel out I can strong
that's big enough
PewDiePie quits YouTube saying he's too
tired to go on amazing every word of
what he said is wrong you did it mirror
you did it whenever I see these fake
stories I'm just like have they always
been fake or is it now that it's become
worse you know what it makes you
question sort of what
they're stories that you heard we're
wrong and growing up right
I remember hearing about Michael Jackson
gonna guerrilla or something like that
I'm like wait I don't did that happen
wait a minute
you're dead acute crazy son of a [ __ ]
you Zdenek that's right gamers I'm free
hallelujah okay won't the last bit
goddamn strong really the main reason I
just felt like I was wasting time and it
was it's not a productive side and I
don't want to support it since the N
word multiple times says the N word once
oh dear oh dear cautious you fair I only
said it was it was a gaming moment it
was a gaming moment famous justified
we've all been there Peter PI I'm taking
a break news outlet Peter PI found dead
everywhere else getting 500 coins just
for uploading posts me who spends 40
hours a day I'm ready but still didn't
get any joy this is so sad I upward for
small peepee that's right kids don't
deserve phones all the kids I watched
and liked his vids on their phone and it
give it to me give it to me you don't
deserve it I take it I take it now give
it to mine yeah how is this so identical
didn't Marcie do that on purpose as much
they'd been weeping out on me without
telling me I am so confused
oh heck yeah Oh Hank yet imagine having
a finger a mouse to a photo post on
reddit this was made by mobile users
gang oh really
watch me do it seaming Leslie dad's
after all these years see you next month
see you next year see you next decade
finally I had them all I don't
understand this one small peepee oh I
get I get it okay I get it I got I got I
got it I got it you don't have to
explain the comments please I get it I
understand it's just not funny thank you
thank you
I hate Tannen mainly because he promotes
drugs to fourteen-year-olds the media
I'm gonna pretend I didn't see that oh
yeah well did you know PT pipe weed
through
the nation to a charity good morning
comrades for tonight minecraft
minecraft' fellow minecraft here today
we play minecraft none of that gave
fortnight literally everyone who
believes that uploading gives you free
coins dumb [ __ ] Jesus it wasn't me I'm
so dumb I am bin [ __ ] what there was
dumpster juice in here all along dammit
oh that's so funny
big vp energy very nice enjoy your break
feels you deserve it big bong see you 19
year olds in a couple of weeks last
online six years ago I am worried that I
will enjoy being on a break so much that
I will not come back but it's just a
small chance gamers it will be worth it
when you know you're gonna lose in
tomorrow's exam but you gain 250 coins
that see this as an absolute win small
peepee known now the joke is over mr.
V's plants with twenty million trees 40
million Christmas tree shut down to put
in houses as decoration mr. beast yeah
it's kind of crazy that we all do that
right is it better to get a plastic tree
though I damn small PP drawing of Felix
now that's big P P that's big P P seeing
that beautified the leaders Twitter is
taking a break from you to never pollen
happy back once you realize how nice
life is without thick don't worry gamers
we're having more important things to do
you guys support make it worth it a
thousand times over so I'll be back
don't worry I hate tan I mainly because
she promotes drugs too for Nero's
misfits
what's misfits maybe I just have a
Boomer view on drugs maybe there's
something I don't know but it's
something I I hate in in rap music as
well because it's so hey look literally
who I'm drinking lead yeah cool enjoy
your brain damage it's like it's not
cool PewDiePie I don't understand war
I'm Swedish his Swedish ancestors spend
the burn the women God what happened to
Sweden huh pathetic pathetic beta males
that's all who lives in
Sweden now a lighters were invented in
1.19 people in that's money did me as PP
it made me laugh
I read has tick tock after that's funny
that made me laugh you to community
literally anything ooh mr. B's are
something else cooking up
what is it be sama what is it famous
philosopher I appreciate that you guys
want more philosophy videos but it's
kind of cringe to group me I feel like
so many people fell for that upload me
because I can tell there's somebody
we're up votes anyway I'm gonna end it
there I hope you guys enjoyed this
episode if you did smash like subscribe
gamers we're trying to get 20 million
subscribers before I take a break can we
do it and as always Bing bong Bing Bing
bong Bing bong okay sorry I forgot so
many weeks I'm so sorry but I finally
have the hundred million award the
official hundred million award here it
is amazing some of you guys thought
YouTube's award was a little lackluster
and design-wise so bobbi Duke arts made
it thank you so much this is so cool
presented to PewDiePie for passing 100
million subscribers it feels like the
community is giving me an award which
obviously means a lot and I really
appreciate it it's such high quality
it's apparently made with a couple of
different types of woods handmade by
Bobby Duke arts very nice it feels very
very premium and wait the chair as well
so good and look it can do this so good
I don't know how he did it so high
quality just the chair itself is
impressing I'm gonna put this in the
background so you can see
[Music]
now you are entering a new era where you
shall crafts thy own poop
the hour of our spells and poop grades
is coming
marzia Edgar and buttons need you
the timer you will face but crawlers is
all about
when you are seated on the porcelain
throne
whoopty is the game to play I'm not
supposed to have my opinion about that
but the prices
you